the question i get more than any other
is from young men who say i'm addicted
to porn yesterday i get that all the
time i get it constantly right this is
the biggest one because now we have
these portals to hell in our pockets and
it's brand new really of the last 20
years it really can be applied to any
addiction or any kind of vice or any
temptation in near desperation they'll
write in and say is there any way to get
better is there any way to recover some
lost innocence that was a question last
week is there any way to and the answer
is if you've ever disciplined yourself
or recovered from any sort of addiction
or anything you'll you'll know the
answer is yes eventually there is you
actually can get better you actually the
temptation can go away a little bit you
can and it's because virtue and vice are
habits they're not just we like to we're
in the eternal presence so we want
instant gratification that's not how it
works when you have routine when you
have habits
in virtue then the temptation gets to be
a little less device and it's easier to
do the virtue and then you go back to
the biscuits and then all of a sudden
it's harder to go back to the keto it's
easier